MANO MARKS: Hi, I'm Mano
Marks, developer advocate
from the Google Maps API team.
This is the fourth
video in a series
of four designed to show you how
to get started with the Google
Maps JavaScript API.
In the last video, I
covered adding an API key
to your Maps API loader
and the various parameters
that the loader takes.
In this video, I'll cover
the basics of map options
and getting your maps
to render on a page.
If you've been following
along with this video series,
you have a text document
with this code in it.
As we walk through
this basic HTML page,
you'll see the basic
declaration of elements.
The first thing I want to
point out is the style element.
One of the most common
mistakes that developers make
is to not specify the size of
the div that contains the map.
If you don't declare
a size for the div,
then when the map is
created, it will be created,
but it will be invisible
because the div is size 0.
This isn't part of the Maps API.
It's a basic part of
how HTML and CSS work.
In this sample, we've put the
style in line with the page.
In most cases,
however, you would
like to link to a separate
file containing your style
sheets for ease of
maintenance and reusability.
The next thing you
see is the script tag
that loads the Maps API.
I covered that in
the last video.
Next we'll see the JavaScript
that adds the map the page.
You'll see we declared the map
variable as a global variable.
That's in case you need
it for other functions.
Next there's an
initialize function.
This is where we
actually create the map
and assign it to
a particular div.
In the initialize function,
the first thing we do
is create a map options object.
There are two
required properties
for a map options object.
They are zoom and center.
Zoom we covered in the
first video in the series.
As a reminder, zoom
0 is zoomed way out,
showing the map of
the whole Earth.
Higher zoom levels get
you closer to the map
and show more detail.
We also talked briefly about
center in the first video,
but, as a reminder,
the center of the map
has a lat/long object.
A Google Maps lat/long
object has two properties,
latitude and
longitude, naturally.
You'll see lat/long
objects again,
particularly in various kinds
of overlays, like markers.
There's a whole
host of parameters
that you can use in
a map options object.
For more information, check
out the reference at this URL.
Going back to the
initialization function,
we create the map
object and assign it
to the map canvas element.
There's nothing magical
about the name Map Canvas.
It's just one that we've
chosen, and so it shows up
in all of our samples.
You can see in the
body element, there's
a div with the ID
map-canvas, which
is where the map
object will render.
Lastly, we add a Google
Maps DOM listener.
This is a DOM listener that
waits for the page to load
and triggers an
initialize function.
That will prevent the
map from rendering
before the page is ready.
OK, that's it.
You have the basics you
need for creating a map.
If you are having any
trouble getting your map up
and running, you might
consult this video
on troubleshooting
and common issues,
and our support
page has links off
to the right tags
on Stack Overflow.